Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
James Gunn just made some official announcements
about Superman Legacy, so we'll break it all down.
We already know who
most of the characters are going to be.
He clarified some of the storylines too,
and there have been a few surprise
characters that I did not expect
that were going to be in the movie.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There's a bunch more that he'll be revealing
in the next couple of months as they start
to fill in the movie.
So whatever they wind up revealing,
of course I will do videos about it.
It's meant to be like the true beginning of his DCU,
even though he's revealed that creature Commandos
is technically going
to be the actual beginning of the DCU, even though
some of the characters from the DCU like Blue
Beetle will come back in the DCU, we still don't
quite know when creature commandos is happening
but I'll talk about that later in the video.
probably the biggest news you probably saw
on your feeds this morning is that he confirmed
officially that Nicholas Hoult will play the new DCU,
Lex Luthor.
The funny thing about this
is that he actually auditioned for the Matt Reeves
Batman that Robert Pattinson wound up getting in fail,
like he talked about failing the Batman audition.
So it really fulfills that Dark Knight line.
You live long enough.
You see yourself become the villain.
doesn't it
sound like Lex Luthor is a person who sees himself
as the hero of the story,
but winds up being twisted dark
and becoming one of the biggest villains?
it sounds like that'll kind of
be his character progression
over the future of the DCU movies,
where he'll start out being like this normal tech
billionaire that will slowly be twisted evil,
eventually becoming one of the biggest villains.
but part of the idea is that in Superman
legacy, he's not meant to be the main villain.
He'll just be one of the antagonists in the background.
Probably
not even that big of an antagonist of Superman.
But that will use him in other future.
Non Superman crossover movies.
Superman sequels, of course, in success.
Assuming they do a trilogy of new Superman movies
in eventually
the new versions of whatever
their Justice League movies wind up turning into.
Even though James Gunn hasn't announced when that next
Justice League movie is actually going to happen.
So there is they're not just casting Nicholas
Hoult for Superman Legacy or the Superman movies.
Lex Luther is probably going to be one of the biggest
upcoming characters
in the Superman mythos across
all the upcoming DCU movies.
James Gunn's official statement just reads, Yes,
I can finally answer.
Nicholas Hoult is Lex Luthor in Superman Legacy?
And I couldn't be happier.
We went out to dinner last night
to celebrate and discuss how we can create a Lex
that will be different
from anything you've seen before.
And we'll never forget Then he goes on to say, But,
James, we heard this weeks ago.
Why didn't you tell us that was true at the time?
Because although we were discussing it,
it wasn't final until a couple of days ago.
And I don't want to tell you something
that isn't certain.
I did a video a couple of weeks ago.
It seems like it was actually just a little while ago
after his casting was announced by all the trades
pretty much everywhere on social media.
Like you probably remember a while ago,
I spent a lot with him as a character.
He's very manipulative,
smart and cruel, but also makes sense
and is jockeying for position, as you say.
And within this court and using all the pieces
and people he can to to get the results
he wants James going to just saying
that he waited a little bit longer
because apparently at the time
the contract had not been absolutely finalized
in stone, like the ink wasn't quite dry yet,
but if you look at the time stamp on Nicholas Hoult
the social media post here it's from last week
he essentially confirmed the news himself
in so many words and it sounds like last week
is when the contract was officially finalized
And even though I'm only capturing part of the replies
here, I love that everyone is replying
using Smallville references like particularly Michael
Rosenbaum's version of Lex Luther
As James Gunn said,
they're planning on Nicholas Hoult version
being totally different
from all the other versions we've seen before.
He's also talking about movie versions in addition
to TV versions like Michael Rosenbaum's Lex.
part of the idea, I think, is that unlike Henry Cavill,
Superman, Jesse Eisenberg's
Lex Luthor relationship in Man of Steel, Batman v
Superman, the Justice League movie
or previous movie versions of Lex Luthor, for example,
Superman Legacy is supposed to take place
so early in Superman's career,
most of the world doesn't really know about him yet.
They'll also probably take advantage of that
and say that Lex Luthor
also probably learns about him
for the first time during the movie in unlike the Jesse
Eisenberg Lex Luthor he doesn't start out
hating Superman's guts from the start.
so. The progression of the Superman Lex Luthor
relationship will be very different than what we saw
in, say, like the Batman v Superman movie in
it'll be a little bit more like the Michael Rosenbaum
Lex Luther in Smallville Superman relationship
with Tom Welling's version of the character.
We're over the course of multiple movies.
Like it'll take a little while.
Lex Luther will slowly grow to mistrust
and eventually hate Superman.
Then much later on, he'll try to start working against
him, tearing down his name and trying to kill him.
that's kind of the way they did things on Smallville.
And it does seem like James
Gunn is cooking a lot of Smallville energy
in this Superman legacy from the start.
part of the idea on Smallville
is that they did actually genuinely start as friends,
but they sort of keeping secrets from each other,
primarily Superman, and keeping his secret from Lex
Luthor in eventually it causing him to mistrust him
and then slowly hate him.
but that took many many years
for that to wind up happening.
But I think part of the idea is that they do want
Nicholas Hoult, the version of Lex Luthor,
to feel different from Michael Rosenbaum's Lex,
even though they're seem that they're borrowing
some of the energy of that character.
so the idea is that this new version of Lex
Luthor will not have grown up in Smallville
alongside Superman being his best friend
when they were kids.
He'll probably be learning about him
for the first time in Metropolis after Superman
reveals himself to the world
as Superman with the Superman identity.
if you don't remember back in the day,
a lot of Michael Rosenbaum's Lex backstory was invented
purely for the Smallville TV show with them
changing the comic book backstory
so that they could use Lex as a major character
in Superman's early life in his development,
becoming Superman.
Eventually, instead of having to wait
until Superman got to Metropolis,
Pretty much most of the show
was him growing up in Smallville, only taking things
the metropolis full time in the final seasons
and if you don't remember the ironic thing about that,
like kind of a funny thing
is that by the time Superman or Clark Kent
made it to Metropolis full time,
and the Daily Planet on the show started working there,
Michael Rosenbaum had actually left
the show as a full time character.
they introduced the concept to the Daily Planet
around the middle of the show.
But Clark didn't really start working there
full time in Metropolis until season eight.
in Michael Rosenbaum
left the show full time as a character in season seven.
He only came back a couple times for cameos after that,
which he's talked about at length.
James Gunn even admitted to him face to face
that he is one of the best versions of Lex
Luther that he's ever seen so far.
he's not lying.
Michael Rosenbaum's
Lex Luthor is one of the best versions of Lex,
but that's because they had so many years
to develop the character.
So we'll see if they can actually top that
with Nicholas Hoult portrayal, the character.
He's an amazing actor,
so I definitely think he has it in him.
Most people will remember him
from the X-Men movies, but it does sound like
because they're recasting all the X-Men
in, they're bringing back the classic versions
of the X-Men and Deadpool three and Secret Wars.
They don't have big plans for his version of Beast.
Like, we literally just saw the Kelsey Grammer
version of BS in the Marvel's movie Post-Credits scene.
so. Even though Nicholas Hoult had a good experience
working on the X-Men movies,
it just sounds like they didn't
have big plans for his characters.
I was like,
okay, I'm free to go off to the DC Universe now.
they just cast
Sarah Sampaio playing his Miss Tess marker.
But outside of that,
we haven't heard about any more castings from Lex Korp
like Mercy Graves or anyone like that.
I know a lot of people have asked about that character.
Maybe she'll show up eventually.
I've talked about this before.
But even though I loved Henry Cavill's
version of Superman,
I was not a huge fan of the Jesse
Eisenberg version of Lex Luthor.
His version was a little bit more like the Mark
Zuckerberg Facebook version of Lex Luthor.
but to be fair That is pretty true to real life.
Like a lot of the younger tech
billionaires out there in the world
are coming from the world of tech
and social media platforms.
just hoping that in this new DCU, James Gunn does not
include any random jars of piss or anything like that.
there was a Lex Corp Easter egg during the Blue Beetle
movie in the Palmyra city skyline in his hometown.
He's one of the first characters
we know are coming back in the new DCU movies,
but that's about as close
as we've gotten to Lex Corp Easter Eggs in the new DCU.
probably the other biggest news recently is a reported
that the new version of Supergirl
will also be in Superman Legacy in some way.
Before the news,
I assumed that they'd only reference her
lightly at most and like she wouldn't be seen on screen
just because there are so many characters
that are already confirmed to be in that movie.
seriously, this is the list
and this is just some of the major characters.
There's still a couple others
that James Gunn has not announced yet.
But he did announce that they're doing
the Supergirl solo movie
based on The Woman of Tomorrow comic book story.
of my favorite comic book series from last year
was Tom King's run on Supergirl, Woman of Tomorrow.
And so we're going to turn that into a big science
fiction epic film.
Now, Superman is a guy who was sent to Earth
and raised by loving parents.
We're Supergirl in this story.
She is a character
who was raised on a chunk of Krypton.
She watched everybody around her
perish in some terrible way.
So she's a much more jaded character.
if she's going to be in Superman Legacy,
even like a small cameo scene, my assumption
is that it's to help set up that solo movie
and just establish that she does
exist in the universe
in what her relationship with Kal-El is.
but none of the reports
actually say what she's going to be doing in the movie.
So I don't think it's going to be a super huge role.
one of the only things that we know is that it will not
be Sasha K's Supergirl from The Flash movie,
which does seem kind of like a downer
because she did a pretty decent job during that movie.
I think a lot of people were hoping
that she would return as the new version of Supergirl.
My assumption
is that James going to just trying to recast
as many of the big Justice League
level roles as possible, Supergirl being one of them
also because they're planning on
doing this new Supergirl solo movie.
So he wants the director
or like whoever's working on the Supergirl solo movie
to actually be involved
in the casting of the new version of Supergirl.
there was like a completely different
ending to the Flash movie meant
to set up her version of Supergirl
becoming part of Henry Cavill
Superman's mythos and whatever
The next Man of Steel two movie was going to turn into.
I did a much longer video about what
that scene was, what they actually cut from the movie.
So I'll link it below in the description
because there's a lot of stuff that they cut from
the movie because they made it before James
Gunn was hired to reboot the DCU
they hired him
and they basically had to go in and change
the endings of a bunch of these current movies
that are happening this year.
a lot of it was meant to set up a Crisis
on Infinite Earths Justice
League movie, which they're actually doing next year,
but it's animated for the Tomorrow verse.
There's like a three part Justice League
Crisis on Infinite Earths movie.
I've already done a trailer video for that,
so link for that in the description below to the other
big DC show that's happening
next year is the Penguin Batman HBO series.
I've already done a trailer video for that too.
A link it at the end of this, but it'll be completely
separate to like the Robert Pattinson Batman universe.
Elseworlds not connected to the DCU stuff.
Let me know in the comments though.
Who do you want to play
this new version of Supergirl inside the DCU
and if you have any big requests for DC videos
before the end of the year
there's a lot of big stuff coming up,
so make sure to enable alerts for my channels
So you don't miss any of that stuff
Click here for that full Batman Penguin HBO Series
Trailer and click
here for that brand new Deadpool
3 Teaser and Wolverine.
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!